quand on vous allez dévaliser un Foot
Locker un Sephora un magasin de Lacoste
ou un magasin de téléphone portable
c'est pas un message politique qui est
envoyé une trompons pas là-dessus c'est
clairement du pillage une nuit plus
calme mais bien loin d'un retour à la
normale des pillages ont eu lieu
notamment chez ce Concessionnaire dans
les quartiers nord il y a plus de 700
personnes interpellées et alors à
l'heure à laquelle on se parle les
services de la justice de notre pays
sont totalement mobilisés
de soutenu avec la Surmont trop front
l'intégrité de la République et
l'intégrité des commerces
qui fait que depuis 2005 4 millions
d’étrangers ont obtenu un titre de
séjour légal dans notre pays on est
responsable et on porte une
responsabilité très lourde dans la
situation de guerre civile qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui comme des incendiaires
idéologiques comme certains d'extrême
gauche qui donne des listes de ce qui
pourrait être attaqué ou pas
manifestement les domiciles des élus
n'était pas dans cette liste qu'il ne
fallait pas attaquer cette absolument
scandaleux cette attitude de l'extrême
gauche ni pèse et Monsieur Mélenchon en
premier ont incité à brûler des écoles à
brûler des bibliothèques justement
hier au milieu du champ de bataille ce
matin une odeur de brûler se dégage
encore devant la maison du maire Victor
jambran vers 1h30 cette voiture enflamme
a été projetée contre son portail tenue
de la gravité extrême de ces faits
la qualification de tentative
d'assassinat a été choisi par le parquet
et tout sera mis en œuvre
pour confondre les auteurs et les
traduire devant la justice on a tous été
très choqués par l'attaque du domicile
de Monsieur le Maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
domicile dans lequel était présent son
épouse et ses enfants et là on a un cap
évidemment qui a été franchi et moi ce
que je veux dire c'est évidemment comme
l'ont fait la première ministre le
ministre de l'intérieur on a en effet
quelque chose d'absolument
invraisemblable attaquer le domicile
d'un élu avec une voiture bélier c'est
sa femme ses enfants étant sur place ça
dépasse le sens commun et ça mérite une
réaction à la hauteur de la part de la
justice et le gouvernement hivérant j'ai
vu j'ai pris en photo moi-même des
inscriptions sur les murs de cette cité
en disant on va brûler la mairie et les
keufs le lendemain il y avait la même
inscription me concernant d'ailleurs qui
appelait à me brûler pourquoi ne pas
avoir instauré des IR le couvre-feu dans
votre ville je l'ai fait hier à 20h et
bien écoutez un peu tardivement parce
que j'attendais du président de la
République effectivement donc les
annonces de l'après-midi des mesures
fortes ne l'a pas fait et donc on a pris
nos responsabilités plus de 10000 furies
réunis dans les rues de Pittsburg en
Pennsylvanie c'est tout simplement le
plus grand rassemblement au monde
j'appelle naturellement au calme au
retour à la paix civile on est dans une
forme aujourd'hui de guérilla urbaine
dans certaines
de guérilla urbaine le furier considéré
comme un mouvement culturel relativement
étrange méconnu encore du grand public
et qui consiste à attribuer aux animaux
vous le voyez des caractéristiques
humaines